questions you should always be a little
suspicious
except for when you know sometimes um
you'll get like when you're starting out
for instance
in this exam very often you'll get
part question one a b c it might be for
instance
differentiate three completely
independent
um functions okay um and we put we group
them together because we want you to do
the same thing
to all three even though they have
nothing to do with each other okay
however when you've got a question like
this
you've got some kind of information
that's common and you're sort of
building up
you should always be thinking okay
they're usually trying to lead me down
a um a particular direction to solving
the question
okay in fact we could sort of if we were
being mean
right um and we wanted to see if you can
do that sort of conceptual leap type
thing
right if we wanted to put this in a
later section we would just give you
this question
without the lead in okay because the
point of part one or part a
right is to say well look here's some
information you solve that
that'll help you with the next part okay
so just keep that in your mind
let's do part one together okay
usually we we call this alpha and beta
but it's all the same as just slightly
different labels okay
so when we're working at n plus n uh m
n and m squared plus
n squared all you need is your sum and
product of roots
okay that's what we're doing here yeah
so let's start with the sum
the sum of the two roots what's the
result remember what fraction is it
minus minus b on a right so
minus b would be positive
one and a is also one so that's not too
hard
okay product of roots is c on a
right which is three now m squared plus
n squared
would you remember what's the trick that
we use for this
okay you're going to need to remember
this comes from
one of these has to be squared right
because you've got m squared and n
squared the question is which one
it's probably going to be this one
because they're separate but then you
have to compensate right so this is
going to be
m plus m or squared
but then it's got extra stuff so you
have to subtract 2mn
yeah just ringing about okay so you've
got one squared minus
six so this is minus five okay so far so
good now when you're looking at this
next part
they're asking you to construct a new
quadratic equation
which has roots alpha and beta okay and
where alpha beta these two things
okay so therefore how do you go about
this well if you just want alpha and
beta you'd say that equation
looks like this
this quadratic equation has roots alpha
and beta
okay however of course they give us more
specific details on what alpha beta are
so we need to
bring those in and try and simplify out
okay and in fact the actual answer this
is what people are puzzling over
the actual answers no m's or n's in it
it's just numbers right
and so it's like where did they come
from okay so before i do that i'm just
going to
factorize these two that's going to make
it a little bit easier when i expand out
do my algebra this is a common factor m
and this has a common factor m sorry
that's n minus all right
yeah okay good so now when i bring this
in here
okay first let's just substitute it will
look gross and we'll get more gross when
we expand it out but we've got to try
and remember
these numbers here are going to be
useful to us later on all right
questions just how so here i've got x
minus alpha
and this is x minus beta
yep just straight substitution now here
in order to get from
this kind of thing which is correct just
not simplified up to
connected to these right i've got to
expand out i've got to get these
m's and these ends talking to each other
and factorizing so i can get in some of
these terms
okay so let's see what we can do when i
just do a straight
expansion
which before i do a straight extension i
might have
said it again
like expand
this bit oh yeah yeah see what you mean
um
yeah yeah so we've got here what do we
got
um x squared minus
alpha this would be alpha plus beta
right i think sum of alpha and beta
uh plus alpha beta
is that right i skipped a step because
i'm going to get minus alpha
x and minus beta x so that's why they
come together yeah odds slow
yes very good um okay now now i'll put
it in because there's my alpha and my
beta
so x squared minus
the sum of these yeah so
minus n n
that's alpha plus beta x and now i have
to take the product
yeah okay
okay now this does it's difficult
and don't ask me to try and say that
sentence because it's kind of like how
much wood
could a woodchuck chuck
but how are we gonna how we're gonna
make this better right what i notice
first
is i've got n minus n and i've got n
minus
m now there's gonna be some factorizing
i can do
once i get things in the right order
right so for instance
up the front here to change this n minus
m into an m minus n hey how terrible
that is so much better
what do i have to do i have to take out
a factor of
minus one right so minus n
see what i did there is that okay
all i need to do is draw attention to
what anyway okay
same deal here right the m and the n
are going to come together sorry that's
an x right
m n okay i can call this
m minus n or squared if
i take out a negative right so in fact i
might
put my negative there okay and what i'm
left with is m
minus n all squared okay
good so far here what do i have
x squared minus if i take out my factor
of m minus
n what i'm left with is m minus
n so actually it's just m minus n or
squared
and what do i have over here
okay now i'm almost there okay can you
see
this expansion and simplifying that kind
of thing what i'm trying to get to is
things like this
this is useful to me right because i
know exactly what mn is
it has a numerical value okay so i can
sub that out
almost okay but then i'm left with these
m minus n
or squares okay which which don't appear
on our list
but we can make an opinion on this right
how do you get m minus n or squared plus
n
minus something okay
when you expand this right this is m
squared plus
n squared we have to add minus
to mn right yeah you see it okay
so therefore this is that's minus five
right minus two m n uh this again
i'm doing it again right so this is
minus six
right yep uh yeah
okay so now i have all my pieces okay
down here i can say that's going to be x
squared plus 11x
plus 11 yep and then here i need to
take the um the product so that's going
to be plus 33